hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor in today's video we're going
to be talking about a special type of
evolution that is known as adaptive
radiation adaptive radiation has two
particular things that distinguish ish
the first is the fact that it is a type
of evolution that happens quite rapidly
so it is a rapid evolution a rapid
evolution of what well of a lot of
diversity so exact of radiation is the
rapid evolution of diversity adapted
species from a common ancestor when at
least one of three things is occurring
that is whenever there are suddenly new
resources available in the environment
or when in a given environment suddenly
new challenges to survival are presented
that allow new traits to be selected for
also the opening of new environmental
niches so this would be when suddenly
there are either new habitats and your
sub habitats or new micro environment
you can a larger environment that are
suddenly available for species to move
into now
adaptive radiation may follow a few
different types of events one is mass
extinctions
for example the fossil record indicates
that there was a significant adaptive
radiation to a rapid evolution
after her species following the mass
extinction of the dinosaurs and in
particular those species that were
rapidly evolving were mammals and so
with the elimination of the dinosaurs
with their disappearance from the earth
they're no longer inhabiting specific
niches using up resources acting as
predators etc that allowed mammals to
really burst onto the scene and that
idea of bursting onto the scene is
something that we see with adaptive
radiation because it is so rapid and
because there are so many species that
result in a fairly short amount of time
another way that adaptive radiation may
occur is the evolution of novel
characteristics for example once mammals
developed a fourth cusp and their molars
this allowed mammals to suddenly be able
to eat food sources that previously were
not able to chew up and so the evolution
of that new characteristic in mammalian
teeth that allowed a lot of additional
adaptive radiation new species to form
very quickly etc because that new
characteristic essentially made new
resources available another example of
adaptive radiation is when it follows
colonization of new habitats this is
when a common ancestor makes it to a new
habitat where there are new
environmental niches and really does
well with multiple species developing
from that common ancestor in a short
amount of time the most well-known
example of this is actually Charles
Darwin's finches these finches of the
Galapagos Islands all descended from a
common ancestor from the mainland had
somehow made these islands and there
were different islands different food
sources different micro environments
within that larger island environment
that different ventures could inhabit
and eventually lead to many different
bench species again in a fairly short
amount of time relative to the
background speciation rate so once again
you take home point here with adaptive
radiation its evolution of the new
species it is very very rapid resulting
in many new species with quite a lot of
diversity because of some of these
changes that can occur in environments
so that is the end of talking today
about adaptive radiation thank you for
watching biology professor and I hope
you learned a lot